azim we're seeing so many cricketers
putting their hands up and saying that
they experienced abuse too
you clearly went through
a huge ordeal yesterday speaking so
personally about that do you think now
it seems like it was worth it
um yeah i do i think the last couple of
years in particular
i feel like yesterday was
a start to show me that it's all been
worth it but i think that's all it is
it's very important that
victims are feeling
like they're going to be heard if
they're coming forward they clearly have
some sort of trust that people are going
to listen to them and make changes and i
think i see that as a massive progress
that
people are coming forward in in their
numbers how did you feel giving that
evidence we could see the pain that was
so evident
yeah
i mean i wish we weren't there yesterday
i wish we never got to this um and i
tried everything to
to stop it getting here but i think it
there was a point that i became very
evident that this was the only way that
ecb the pca and yorkshire were going to
listen
and i think a lot of things have
happened in the lead up to this but i
think the threat of this
yesterday was what uh has um and the
sponsors leaving has what's uh sped up
the process but yeah look i think it's
all been worth it and
for now but it's important that moving
forward this is seen as only the start
as opposed to
the end what you have said
has created some career-ending moments
for some individuals
clearly what you suffered was appalling
but do you think
the way of doing it this way
is a fair process
well this is
i think that's where
the pca
the ecb
and yorkshire county creek i've got i've
got a lot to answer for um because i
tried to deal with it in
the quietest way possible
uh all i was wanting is some sort of
acceptance and a sorry and an answer to
why uh in certain but
yorkshire in trying to protect the
institution have thrown a lot of their
players and past players and coaches
under the bus in my opinion um as for me
as i'm trying to make it very clear it's
never been about the individuals and
hopefully
hopefully um
for everyone that apologizes that
accepts it i hope it's not going to be a
career-ending
um
testimony
but like i said i think it it's the
wrong person to be looking at i think
they need to look at solely at yorkshire
county club supported by squire pattern
bogs and
that panel that's the legal firm that
was involved in the oversight of the the
process looking into your allegations
you say it's not about institutions it
has become about individuals which of
those individuals have spoken to you
since you gave evidence to mps yesterday
um david lloyd reached out
and apologized i told him how i felt
about the cop the stuff he said
and the fact that he didn't know me it
was clear that it hadn't come from him
um he'd been briefed um by someone uh i
was close to yorkshire county creek club
so it was disappointing i told him
exactly how i felt but he apologized i
accepted his apology and
he's
put a commitment there that he's going
to help move this
game and society in the direction that
we wanted to go in but you've not heard
from anyone else connected to yorkshire
county qriket club since you gave
evidence yesterday no i don't think any
of them think they've done anything
wrong
i i mean i'd still and it's staggering
um
the arrogance
of these people
actually they're they're helping prove
what exactly what i'm saying i mean mark
arthur's resignation letter it was like
a cv
i mean uh he listened to his
achievements
without mentioning racism yeah and he
talked about a
50 catering contract i mean
read the roommate like and it just shows
exactly where these people are and they
don't care
and that's the fundamental part of how
the charge of institutional racism is
levied at them because
you don't see any contrition you don't
see any
willingness to change
do you think lord patel is the new
chairman at headingley
can facilitate and make that happen
um i think he's started well
but the structures are the same
how much and he will be able to do only
time will tell
i admire the fact that he was very
honest with me
and look he knows everyone's watching
i'm watching and we're gonna be calling
it out if if it doesn't change it's
pretty clear that there needs to be a
total clear out
the 14 people who signed a letter to the
board to discredit me
because i don't share white rose values
according to them
so
it's clear that it's so that in the
environment so embedded in there that
they still don't see what they've done
wrong a total clear out means
all those 14 individuals having no
further connection to the club and
people on the board going more people
more resignations
yeah i don't think anyone in leadership
can stay uh i don't think you can leave
one
in there because that will cause him i
think more from lord patel than uh
i mean
yeah then 14 people i don't think uh if
they're coaches players
members of the staff whoever it is i
don't think they should be
i don't think they should be involved in
an organization that clearly has got a
lot to do um hopefully there was no
players in that but there is if there is
i think they've got to go when gary
balance put out his statement
apologizing and trying to set his
version of what happened he made some
pretty strong accusations towards things
that you had said to him that he would
anticipate that you would regret did
that happen
well gary's statement was um quite
weird for me because i didn't feel like
there was an apology
and um i think some of the things that
he was actually talking about were
actually not correct so there seemed to
be a thing about uh it was all when i
was younger
when a 2017 pre-season tour is
four years ago so i think it would have
been 27 so
it that definitely isn't true um
i actually
uh thought everyone got what i'd alleged
against them and got a chance to respond
i didn't get any of that so i don't
really know what has been alleged
against me um
like i said um there's
there was a massive closing of the ranks
i think out of 29 people 23 or something
were
the
club employees or club individuals and
i mean
i don't even know what they've
collaborated together to say that i've
done um
and that's that's where we are with that
but
yeah i was pretty disappointed by the
statement cricket is a sport you clearly
love and and still love
but
it's got a culture hasn't it the
sledging is a big part of the game the
mickey taking the kind of embedded
kind of male dominated in a lot of
environments
kind of bravado is it capable of change
um
i'm not sure i think it needs
uh the media
the politicians the government to
push them and because i think if we
if we switch off in three weeks time
um i think these guys will go back to
them everywhere and carry on as before
um i think this uh
and not just from a race point of view
from gender as well and other types of
discrimination
like i said to this point i've not seen
anything from the game or its leaders
that shows me they're willing to change
hopefully yesterday's shifted that a
little bit the prime minister commended
you yesterday personally for showing the
bravery that you showed in coming
forward what do you make of boris
johnson
[Music]
making that
kind of commendation towards you
um look
i'm really thankful to the politicians
in the last few weeks i think their
intervention has
made a big difference in um
yorkshire being held to account the ecb
coming under pressure and hopefully the
pca as well
um
i think i'd just encourage them to make
sure they've keep an eye on this and
cricket goes back to well not even goes
back to qriket becomes a game beautiful
game that it should be that it's never
been
what is
the thing that stuck with you most from
yesterday
that i mean did you go further in
explaining what you've been through than
you thought
well to be honest i don't even know what
i said yesterday um
i went in there and i just tried to tell
the truth um
the moments are so raw for me that even
right now i can literally feel
them exact moments as i felt them then
um so
yeah the one thing that surprised me
after was how surprised people were
if you ask any person of colour
they'll say i'm not surprised